everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today today let's
solve minimum cost climbing stairs and
this problem is very similar to another
problem that we've solved that's called
climbing stairs and honestly i think
this is probably one of my best videos
explaining dynamic programming i really
walk through
all the steps from recursion to
memorization to dynamic programming so i
will link this video somewhere on the
screen or somewhere on the description
if you want to take a look it's very
similar to the problem that we're
solving right now which is minimum cost
climbing stairs it's just a slight
variation of that other problem so we're
given an integer array called cost where
cost of i is the i step on the staircase
and if we pay that cost at index i then
we can either climb one step or two
steps from index i so in this example
over here we're given an array of 10 15
and 20. what we're told is that if we
pay this cost if we're at this position
right and we pay the cost of 10 from
this position we can either take one
step which will land us in this position
or we can take two steps which will land
us in this position and we only have to
pay a cost of 10 to do that and also we
are told that we can actually either
start at index 0 or start at index 1. so
we can either start from this position
or we can start from this position and
our goal is to reach the top floor of
this staircase so you're probably
thinking okay
let's just start at position uh index
zero right take a jump of 2
which costs 10 right because we're
taking two steps starting from here so
that costs 10 then we reach this spot
and then we're done right we've reached
the top floor so therefore the answer is
10 right well not quite and it's kind of
tricky i think it's really their fault
that they word this problem kind of
poorly in this case the answer is
actually 15. why is it 15 well it's
pretty simple it's because this is the
last position in our cost array but this
is not the top floor the position right
after that is considered the top floor
which
yeah they don't really specify that
anywhere in the description which is
kind of dumb but that's the thing so
the reason why the answer is 15 is
because remember we can either start at
this index or we can start at this index
if we start here then we can take a jump
of 2 which will reach which will land us
at the top of the staircase it only
costs us 15 to do that or we could start
at 10 take a jump of 2 and then take a
jump of 1 which would cost us 30 or we
could from 10 jump to 15 and then take a
double jump which would cost us 25 10
plus 15
so clearly the minimum was when we start
at 15 and then just take a jump of two
so then the result is 15. so then your
next idea might be let's just be greedy
right why not always you know let's
start at one of the positions either
this one or this one and then always
take two steps right why exactly would
we ever want to take one step when we
could take two steps right and it costs
us the same amount well there's an
answer to that question and let me show
you an example a counter example of why
sometimes we would want to take one step
rather than two the main reason is
because maybe if we take two steps
there's a value over here something like
a thousand right a really big number and
then we'd have to either take one step
or two step but either way we'd have to
cut it would cost us a thousand if we
land here or we could take maybe one
step and yeah we'd have to pay 15 and
then have to pay a 20 and then we could
though take two steps uh to maybe a
value over here that's really small like
five which would skip us a value like
over here which would be a thousand so
you can't really be greedy and actually
the second example down here is another
reason
is another counter example of why we
can't always take two steps
so let's really try to understand how we
can at least brute force this problem
because we've noticed that from every
spot we have two decisions right take a
jump of one or take a jump of two and we
can't just be greedy and take a two jump
every single time so let's try every
single possibility and if you've watched
any of my videos you know that we like
to do decision trees when we're brute
forcing so
suppose we start here we start at index
0 and we have you know 0 1 2 to this
index and this index is out of bounds
and that's when we know we've reached
the goal and we can stop so initially we
start at zero right we can either jump
to index one or index two and the cost
if we jumped to index one would be ten
the cost if we jump to index 2 would
also be 10. now if from index 1 we can
either jump once right meaning we jump
to index 2 or we can do a double jump
and jump to index 3. of course if we're
at index 1 the cost to jump from there
is going to be 15 whether we take a one
jump or if we take a double jump from
index two we actually only have one
choice we can take a single jump which
will land us at index three which is
actually out of bounds if we take a
double jump we'll get to index 4 which
doesn't really make any sense because
that's also out of bounds so in this
case
the cost from jumping from index 2 is 20
so we can put that now just so you know
once we reach index 3 which we already
have done in two of our
paths as you can see
we can't really go any farther from here
right so what we're going to say is as
we've stopped here we want to know okay
we reached the end right we want to know
what was the minimum cost to reach this
position so
one path if we jump like this the cost
was 10 plus 15 which is 25 right that's
the total cost to reach this
taking this path it was 10 plus 20 which
is larger it took 30 to reach this spot
but we're not quite done yet we know we
can't go in this direction so you know
we're done here but there's still one
node in our decision tree that we can
continue to traverse so from index 2 we
can take another single jump and then
get to index three and of course that's
going to cost 20 to do that and so the
cost is 20. so you can already tell that
this is definitely not the solution this
took about what 45 to reach uh index
three so definitely not good you can see
there were three different ways for us
to reach uh the goal
and among all of these the minimum was
25 but remember if we go back to the
actual description the answer to this
problem was actually 15 so why didn't we
end up with the correct answer and it's
pretty simple because remember we were
allowed to start at index zero or
allowed to start at index one but
clearly in this decision tree we started
at index zero so don't we have to draw
another entire decision tree starting at
index one well if you're clever and you
take a look at this picture you know
starting from index one don't we already
have that entire decision tree just look
over here right we started at index one
here now we did do some work before we
got to index one but can't we just
pretend like that doesn't exist can't we
just reuse this entire decision tree
obviously we'd have to modify the
numbers a tiny bit right because
when we
start from here the cost so far is not
10 it's actually zero because we're
pretending like we actually started from
here right and that will be easy to
handle for us if we recursively
implement this solution uh so what i'm
saying is for us if we started at at one
you know we'd put a path over here on
the right and then get to three and the
cost for that would be 15 not 25 as we
have down here and the other path where
we go left we go uh jump to position two
and then jump to position three that
would cost us 15 plus 20 which means the
total would be 35
rather than 45 right so not 45 over here
it would actually be 35. the main point
of what i'm trying to show you is
there's repeated work here right if we
take this solution as it is it's
exponential because it's a decision tree
each node is going to have two branches
right up to two branches and we're gonna
keep doing that until we get to the base
case right which is index three so
what's the possible height the max
height of this tree well we could have a
potential level for every single
position in the input array right so the
height of the tree is going to be n
which is equal to the length of the cost
array right so n is equal to the length
of the cost array and we know that we
could have two branches for every single
node so the time complexity comes to two
to the power of n but as we just showed
there's a lot of repeated work that
we're doing if we eliminate that
repeated work we can actually get this
time complexity down to big o of n
because what we're noticing is to solve
the original problem which is what's the
minimum cost if we start at index 0 to
reach index 3. to solve this problem
we're asking a couple more questions
we're basically solving the sub problem
we're asking okay how about to solve
this problem we have to first figure out
if we're starting at index one what's
the minimum cost of reaching index three
and to solve this problem we're asking
another sub problem down here okay what
about if we start at index two then
what's the minimum cost to arrive at
index three so if we cache this repeated
work
with a hash map or something so that we
don't repeat the same problem multiple
times what i'm saying is over here you
can see that we start at index two and
we wanna know how what's the cost to
reach index three well it turns out that
it was twenty right from two to get to
three it costs twenty so then when we're
trying to solve that same sub problem
over here starting at index two how much
does it cost to get to index three well
it was 20. we don't actually have to run
through that because we already solved
that problem over here right so that's
the main idea of how we can get this to
big o of n the reason it's big o of n is
because we have n sub problems we're
asking okay from index zero how long
does it take to get to three from index
one how long does it take to get to
three from index two how long does it
take to get to three so that will be an
o of one operation for each position in
the array which will be n time
complexity it'll also be o of n memory
complexity and if we take this idea of
caching the recursive solution we can
actually get an iterative solution that
i'm going to show you now which will
have the same time complexity and you
know pretty much the same memory
complexity as well so now let's actually
go over the real dynamic programming
solution which will actually have a
slightly better memory complexity
because we can actually use the input
array itself that we're given and we
could actually even just use two single
variables to do the dp solution let me
show you why so we noticed that to solve
the original problem right starting from
index 0 what's the minimum cost to reach
the out of bounds position or the top of
the staircase we first have to solve the
sub problem of starting from one and
starting from two right so basically
this has a dependency of this and this
but we also learned that this has a
dependency of this and this and
basically every one of these cells has
that dependency so how about we actually
solve this problem from right to left
rather than from left to right let's
solve the sub problems first and then
solve the original problem okay so does
that mean we're gonna start from index
two we wanna know how what's the cost
for this to reach index three well it
has two choices it can do one jump or
two jumps the second jump doesn't do
anything because it also goes out of
bounds right the first jump will go out
of bounds so that's enough for us and
what's the cost to reach 3 well it's
going to be just 20. yes that works so
we can just leave 20 here right so from
index 2 to reach out of bounds it takes
20. but what about from index 1 now we
kind of get into one of the more
interesting cases right from here we can
also do a single jump so then we're
asking okay if we do a single jump it'll
obviously cost us 15 to do that single
jump but also the value that should be
in this position is from index two how
long does it take to reach index three
because then what we can say is okay for
index one to reach index three we can
just take 15 which was this jump and
then 20 which was the remainder right
the remainder to reach index three so we
can in this position we can put 15 plus
20. but hold on because there's actually
two paths right
we already handled the single jump case
but what if we do a double jump from
index one then what's the cost that we'd
put here well we'd put 15 because that's
the cost of making the double jump but
then we'd want to also add the value
that goes here to that total result
right because from index three how long
does it take to reach index three it's
kind of a weird question logically to
actually ask but just to make the math
work out the easiest number we can put
here is zero right because if we're
already at index three it obviously
doesn't cost anything to to stay here so
that's the reason why we're putting a
default value here of zero now now we
actually have to look at two choices
right because one possibility was we go
here make a single jump to two and then
go to three right the cost of that will
be 15 plus 20. another possibility is we
stay we start here and then just do a
double jump to this position right and
the cost for that is going to be 15 plus
0 because there's a 0 here so we want to
take the minimum of both of these values
what's smaller 35 or 15 of course 15 is
smaller so we're going to put the
minimum of these two computations in
this position and the good thing is it's
already 15. and last we're gonna start
from index zero we're going to see okay
10 plus the cost you know 10 is the cost
for making one jump and then from here
from index one what would be the cost to
you know do the remainder of reaching
index three it's just going to be the
value that's here which is already 15 so
10 plus 15 is 25 that's one possibility
the second possibility would be making a
double jump so from here a double jump
10 plus 20 which is the value here is 30
right so we want to take the minimum of
those two values of course 25 is smaller
than 30 so we put 25 in this position so
now in this array every single index
represents the entire cost it would take
from this index to reach the end of the
array or the top of the staircase from 2
it would be 20 from index 1 it would be
15 and from index 0 it would be 25 now
what value do we actually want to return
remember we can only start at index 0 or
index 1. we can't start at index 2 and
we definitely can't start at the top of
the staircase so what we're going to
return is just going to be what's the
minimum of the first two values in this
array of course the minimum of these two
is 15 so we can just return 15. as you
can see the the time complexity was
definitely big o of n we just you know
iterated through the array in reverse
and the memory complexity is uh
technically big o of one because we're
not really we're just using the input
array itself and you actually don't even
need to use the input array you don't
need to write over the input array
because if you notice as we go in
reverse
you know this value only depends on the
next two values and this only depends on
the next two values so really if you
wanted to you could just keep two
variables in memory rather than even
writing over the entire array and then
as you go in reverse order you could
update those variables to you know the
correct values but it's your choice of
how you want to code it up speaking of
code now we can finally jump into the
coding solution okay so now let's jump
into the code and this is the same
example that we were basically working
on and remember what we wanted was to
just have another extra zero at the end
of the array just to make the math work
out easily for us so that's what we're
going to do to this input array we're
just going to append a zero value to it
and then we want to iterate through this
array in reverse order right so what
index are we going to start at well in
the drawing i started at this index but
remember what we're going to be doing is
taking this and then looking at the next
two values that come after it of course
for the last index or this index that
i'm showing there aren't two values that
come after it so we should actually
start at this index and that makes sense
for us because we're not actually going
to be updating this value because we're
just going to take 20 add it with 0
which doesn't change this value at all
right so that's why we're going to be
starting at this index how we can get
this index is basically the entire
length of the array we know that the
entire length of the array minus 1 will
give us the last position right length
minus 1 will give us this position so
really we can do length minus 3 which
will give us this position which is
where we want to actually start at so
we're going to do the length of the cost
array minus three and this is just how
you do it in python at least with a for
loop and we're gonna decrement uh we're
gonna keep going all the way until we
reach the beginning of the array and
we're gonna decrement by one each time
if you're not familiar with python all
we're doing is just iterating starting
at this position in reverse order from
this array so remember what we want to
do for cost at index i what we want to
assign this to is really the minimum of
cost of index i plus
cost of index i plus one right because
from here if we make a single jump we're
going to land here so we want to add the
value at that position that we land at
to the original position the second
choice is if we make a double jump so
i'm just going to copy and paste this
because it's pretty similar if we make a
double jump this is what
the computation will be like cost of i
plus cost of i plus two but if you want
to actually simplify this line of code
you can see that since both of these
computations have cost of i as the first
uh you know value we can actually just
remove cost of i from both of these and
actually just take the minimum of these
two and add it to the original value so
we can just change this line to this
right take the minimum of these two and
add it to cost of i yeah that's the
entire code just iterate through it in
reverse order do the computation and
then the only thing you have to return
is the minimum of the first two values
of cost of i so
cost of zero and cost of index one and
the main reason that this works is
because we're guaranteed that the cost
array is going to have at least two
values if we weren't guaranteed that
then we couldn't necessarily do this
line over here but let's run it to make
sure that it works let me just delete
this first line up above so we don't get
any errors and as you can see on the
left yes the solution works and it's
pretty efficient so i hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
consider checking out my patreon where
you can further support the channel if
you would like and hopefully i'll see
you pretty soon thanks for watching